-Performing "Next Year" from
Pike Place Market in Seattle,
here's Macklemore
featuring Windser!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Next year's gonna be
better than this year ♪
♪ Next year's gonna be
better than this 'cause ♪
♪ New Year's Eve comin'
with a fresh kiss, yeah ♪
♪ Next year's gonna be
better than this year ♪
better than this 'cause ♪
♪ New Year's Eve comin'
with a fresh kiss, yeah ♪
♪ Next year's gonna be
better than this ♪
-♪ Next year's my come up ♪
♪ I've been lackin' but
I can feel that it's the one ♪
♪ All the last 365 one sucked ♪
♪ Like God group texted
the world and dumped us ♪
♪ Bah, bah, bah, you better
watch my bounce back ♪
♪ I'ma be the man in here ♪
♪ Glass to the sky, like we
tryna grab the chandelier ♪
♪ I'd like to take this
opportunity and toast to me ♪
♪ For bein' exactly
who I'm supposed to be ♪
♪ 'Cause life
is gonna do what life does ♪
♪ I don't wanna look back
and regret who I was ♪
♪ Let go of the expectations
and then fire one ♪
♪ Forget the tally sheet
before all my time's up ♪
♪ And I,
know I gotta roll with it ♪
♪ I'm well aware the universe
doesn't owe me... ♪
♪ I know that, all of this pain
means the growth, I think ♪
♪ That next year's
gonna be better than this ♪
-♪ I'm still an optimist,
yeah, I ♪
♪ Got a lot to live on time ♪
♪ And I ain't foolin' that... ♪
♪ 'Cause next year's gonna be
better than, better than ♪
♪ Next year's gonna be
better than this year ♪
better than this 'cause ♪
♪ New Year's Eve comin'
with a fresh kiss, yeah ♪
♪ Next year's gonna be
better than this ♪
-♪ I'm sick of missin' out,
sick of the fear and doubt ♪
♪ I'ma get spiritual soon,
live in the here and now ♪
♪ Alone in my room,
but you gon' hear me loud ♪
♪ And clear, let's start it
at the top of the year ♪
♪ I want one last cigarette,
one last sip of it ♪
♪ One last secret,
one last little bit ♪
♪ One last upper,
one last sedative ♪
♪ One last supper with
the devil and his relatives ♪
♪ And I was gonna change
my ways ♪
♪ I was just waitin'
for that day ♪
♪ To pull myself
up out of that page ♪
♪ Run that route
and make a play ♪
♪ So sick of sittin'
on the bench ♪
♪ It's finally to get in shape
and livin' like a scrimmage ♪
♪ Thinkin' that I'll get
another day now, no ♪
♪ I ain't wait up
for coach marchin' band ♪
♪ I'ma go and parade
in my zone... ♪
♪ Man in the mirror finally
got on, forget next year ♪
♪ The time is now to press go
and I'm gone ♪
-♪ I'm still an optimist,
yeah, I ♪
♪ Got a lot to live on time ♪
♪ Ain't foolin' that... ♪
♪ 'Cause next year's gonna be
better than, better than ♪
♪ Next year's gonna be
better than this year ♪
better than this 'cause ♪
♪ New Year's Eve comin'
with a fresh kiss, yeah ♪
♪ Next year's gonna be
better than this ♪
better than this year ♪
♪ Next year's gonna be
better than this 'cause ♪
♪ New Year's Eve comin'
with a fresh kiss, yeah ♪
♪ Next year's gonna be
better than this ♪
-Let's go.
The fish is famous!
[ Cheers and applause ]